there's a couple of stories worth
telling from Ronnie's wedding but
everyone's convinced Mt [__] his wife
in the bathroom at the wedding wow
that's the report I got I'm sorry to
report that is not accurate whatsoever
are you lying no no I I did have to go
into the bathroom with her but it was
not for any reason that was sexy at all
throughout the night people are coming
up to me m and Mary had sex in the
bathroom did you hear M and Mary had sex
in the bathroom so I jot down the note
but no one really had any information
other than they heard and then in the
middle of the night somebody introduced
me to a woman at the party who told me
she was in the stall next to Mary and Mt
uh while they were uh in qust and said
she heard everything and it was
definitely 100% SE if I was going to
hook up with my wife I I wouldn't pick
like a bathroom stall hey man that's
just what people were talking about all
night dude I don't know what to tell you
she was in a very tight jumpsuit and in
order to pee she had to like be taken
out of it she needed my help M was
sharing a hotel room the whole time this
is the rumor I don't know if it's true
with your your wife your kid and your
mother-in-law so that was was why you
needed to go to the bathroom to relieve
yourself no there was no uh relation to
the bathroom JD got trash in Vegas holy
[__] did he got trash first of all I
didn't eat all that much at day I just
had breakfast I had a lot of uh San
Blanc and then uh then and then I don't
remember how I got up to my room I ended
up leaving the the wedding at some point
and I wake up to messages from John Hine
asking me if I'm okay JD was so blacked
out drunk that he fell asleep fully
clothed why would you drink to the point
that you black out I mean what's going
on with you for real it's oh first of
all this is not an everyday occurrence I
was at Ronnie's wedding I wanted you
know I wanted to be loose I didn't want
to be you know is the problem where the
[__] I am now first of all you have
trouble speaking you can't afford to
lose brain cells from alcohol you know
every time you drink you get stupider
you know that you're acting like I
passed out at the wedding and [__] uh
like just sat there almost not almost I
was able to gather my bearings enough to
walked to my room by myself and out
wow you telling me you were able to get
to your room all by yourself well it was
[__] Ma to get there at the hotel it was
a maze to get back so
yes at the at the end of the night he
comes over to me he's wearing these
things that blink and all you know all
these like he looked like Liber and he
goes to me he goes I'm so [__] up I
got to get the [__] out of here know
where I am am I got to go to my room I
don't know how to get there but I'm
going to make it oh dear you would have
thought he was uh Neil Armstrong going
to the Moon I don't know where I am but
I'm going to make it but he was having a
good time that's all that mattered was
there any guy who was like a really bad
dancer
like he he is the worst best dancer ever
he tries so hard to dance and he loves
it so much but he is not terrible
terrible Howard he just dances like
Elaine from s it's the ultimate white
guy dancing it kind of reminded me of
that scene from P Fiction with John
trol
dancing these guys saw that I put
together a list of the worst dancers so
they're trying to get to me first that I
was a terrible dancer I guarantee I was
one of you said I'm the second worst
dancer there I didn't dance the whole
night I don't know what you think you
saw you slow danced with Mary it how
could you slow
Dan get a mirror you're a shitty dancer
I'm a very good danc
you know dancing and like all like like
weird undulations like Ed Grimley a
little bit it has an ed Spenders on and
it's like it's like very Larry King it's
it's bizarre it's bad it's bad by the
way I got a report that Ronnie was
shooting a giant air cannon on the dance
floor but nobody understood why like
that's the thing they use at the Nick
game to shoot out t-shirts but Ronnie
didn't have any t-shirts he was just
shooting an air
cannon he look like he was putting out a
fire or a Ghostbuster Hey listen that
was that was her idea not mine T did one
of those things where he he got the mic
and said I'm only going to talk for a
minute and then he talked for 20 minutes
and then he's like I'm done and then
they talk for another 20 minutes Sour's
a pisser I got to tell s has a whole set
yes I said when Stephanie danced to
Daddy's little girl everybody was
confused and then I said by the way
leave the flowers on the table there for
the funeral next
[Laughter]
week the Afterparty is going to be the
Bingo hole first person to a 69 wins an
ass toy from
Ronnie yeah had a whole set a very
loving speech yeah yeah Ronnie I mean I
only heard good things about your vows
the only disparaging thing I heard about
him was that you kind of read like Luca
brzi and The Godfather that you you know
but it was a little weird he does I
think at some point he referred to uh
their their love as like a construction
site with bulldozers and an asphalt or
something I wasn't I didn't follow the
vows compl well Ronnie's a real man you
know he he's like a little boy with
trucks and no dude it it was we we
constructed we con we built a building
with a you know A love with your love
yeah I
mean
l you know what I heard Ronnie no joke
or anything Kurt Bush cried during
Ronnie's vows really for real for real I
a lot of people did from what I you know
people told me afterwards can you read
them because I mean I think guys could
learn something from this even before I
read him at the wedding I said you you
all know me and the way I am with with
saying things that you know the way I
feel about things I I'm not that kind of
person but that you know I wrote this
and I felt this is what I felt and this
is what I wrote and good you don't like
it tough [__] that's simple it that's
the attitude to have all right let me
hear what you got okay so here it goes
look Robin Stephanie by the way okay you
know if you need to I don't have I'm
looking at the paper I don't have to
look at all right good okay go ahead
that's another thing I had to have my
friend type this up so it was big enough
oh wow it was big enough to read so it
was big enough to read my glasses on you
know I don't want have to take my
[__] glasses off to read this [__]
all right I got my tissue ready right
here in case I start crying go ahead
looking at you right now really takes my
breath away you look so beautiful I feel
that we've spent a lifetime together
already 16 years proves our love just
didn't happen overnight we've already
been through the bad times already wait
I'm sorry we've already been through the
bad times already and with our strong
love we built a life together that is so
perfect this day our wedding day has
completed the construction of our
building we can take away the bulldozers
the cranes and say we've done it we are
completed I love how beautiful you look
morning noon and night I love how how
you always care about others I love how
smart you are I Love You for Your Love
of Animals and most of all I love you
for the way you love me you always have
my back and are always there to support
me whether you think I'm right or even
sometimes wrong you always try to make
me see the positive side of everything I
love you for
that we are here we are here today at
this beautiful venue filled with all of
our family and friends to celebrate this
love building we have created and built
together which can never be taken away
we have we have something that I wish
everyone that shares their vows like we
are doing can feel like we do right now
I love you baby girl and can't wait to
say I do to my best friend very ni I
mean beautiful I get the building the
building you know what what's that our
love is like insulation and your heart
is like drywall but it cracked me or
something I that was good stanie I am
the bricks and Stephanie is the mortar I
am the wood beam and Stephanie is the
lolium I am the air conditioner and she
is dent I am the toilet and she is the
plunger I had a suspicion he would uh
get romantic for the day you know what I
mean I had a feeling that I said to the
guy let your heart open up a little bit
yeah I got choked up myself actually and
every time I think about it I get choked
up
well you came through Ronnie I'm proud
of
you